hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 22 hört zu und spricht nach
ich sehe ich sehe du siehst du siehst er
sie es sieht er sie es sieht wir sehen
wir sehen
ihr seht ihr seht sie sehen
sie sehen ich kaufe im supermarkt ein
ich kaufe im supermarkt ein
du kaufst im supermarkt ein
du kaufst im supermarkt ein er sie es
kauft im supermarkt ein wie es kauft im
supermarkt ein wie
kaufen im supermarkt ein wir kaufen im
supermarkt ein
ihr kauft im supermarkt ein
sie kaufen im supermarkt einkaufen im
supermarkt ein
ich kenne
ich kenne mich du kennst dich du kennst
dich er sie es kämpft sich er sie es
kämpft sich wir kennen uns wir kennen
uns ihr kennt euch ihr kennt euch
sie kennen sich sie kämen
ich mache jeden tag die hausaufgaben
ich wasche jede woche die kleider
ich bekomme jeden monat meinen lohn
ich muss jedes jahr die steuern bezahlen
ich dusche jeden morgen
ich schlafe jedes wochenende aus ich
schlafe jedes wochenende aus ich stehe
jeden morgen um sieben uhr auf ich stehe
jeden morgen um sieben uhr auf
etwa drei mal pro jahr ins kino ich gehe
etwa drei mal pro jahr ins kino
ich trainiere viermal pro woche im
fitness center
ich kaufe zweimal pro woche im
supermarkt ein
am montag gehe ich zur arbeit am montag
gehe ich zur arbeit am dienstag rasiere
ich mich am dienstag rasiere ich mich am
mittwoch gehe ich zum zahnarzt am
donnerstag treffe ich freunde am
donnerstag treffe ich freunde
gehe ich aus am freitag gehe ich aus am
samstag sehe ich fern am samstag sehe
ich fern am sonntag schlafe ich aus am
sonntag schlafe ich aus am wochenende
habe ich frei am wochenende habe ich
frei am ersten april habe ich geburtstag
am ersten april habe ich geburtstag
zahnarzt pingitzer mettler kürze
kritischer mettler
hier spricht peter meyer ich brauche
einen termin gerne nächste woche ist ein
termin frei
am mittwoch um 8 uhr nein es ist
dringend ich habe starke zahnschmerzen
ich kann nicht so lange warten geht es
nicht früher
ich habe morgen frei morgen morgen geht
es nur am mittag um halb eins ja das
gibt gut dann ist ihr termin morgen am
dienstag um 12.30 bis dann herr meier
vielen dank auf wiederhören
rathaus kreisbüro basel neff gritti
guten tag frau neff hier spricht smirnow
wie kann ich ihnen helfen herz mehr noch
ich muss meine aufenthaltsbewilligung
erneuern
ich habe aber während der woche keine
zeit ich möchte einen termin für samstag
vereinbaren also diesen samstag am 13
juni hätten wir noch um acht uhr 20 oder
um 11 uhr einen termin frei
rom 11 ist besser dann kann ich
ausschlafen guterres mehr noch ich trage
sie für samstag 11 uhr beide
migrationsbehörde 1
ich brauche noch ihren vornamen und ihre
telefonnummer bitte mein vorname ist
anton meine telefonnummer ist 04 57 1 2
1 3 1 2 1 3 1 2
woher kommen sie herr smirnow und welche
aufenthaltsbewilligung hatten sie bis
jetzt aus russland ich hatte bis jetzt
die aufenthaltsbewilligung b welchen
beruf haben sie ich arbeite als
labortechniker bei roche danke auf
wiederhören herr smirnow auf wiederhören
von f